le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
il faut de l'imagination et du courage
pour créer son entreprise et se sortir
parfois d'une longue période de chômage
pour récompenser et valoriser les
entrepreneurs réunionnais le département
organise chaque année le challenge des
créateurs
l'occasion de mettre en avant les idées
visionnaires de sept jeunes
entrepreneurs locaux comme dit et haber
qui a créé son activité d'opticien
mobile
[Musique]
c'est avec minutie que dj prépare le
matériel pour son intervention du jour
bah quand je fais je le chevet clients
il nous faut au miroir dont là pour
qu'il puisse l'essayer pour que camus
rares ses mobiles
quelques outils comme ça pour pouvoir
régler la monture préférée des branches
didier est opticien à domicile après
plusieurs années d'expérience en magasin
il décide de créer son entreprise mobile
en 2016 l'aînée venus grâce à des
clients des enfants qui venaient faire
de lunettes pour leurs parents qui
étaient donc un peu difficile de faire
des lunettes adaptées personne qui est
pas devant vous pourquoi pas prendre de
mesures savait pas comment il fonctionne
rouler son environnement sa position du
coup petit à petit l'idée mur premier
opticien
encouragé par ses partenaires financiers
le jeune entrepreneur décide alors de
s'inscrire au challenge des créateurs
première réaction a été de me dire j'ai
pas j'ai pas ma chance j'ai gagné et
puis le lendemain au petit réveil guy
non m'at il faut y aller faut y aller
allez montrer pour projet voir la
réaction des des professionnels est
clair face de toi et voir si le projet
plaît le challenge des créateurs est un
concours organisé par le département
pour valoriser les entrepreneurs
réunionnais aujourd'hui lorsque le
département ouvrent ce challenge des
créateurs et il le fait depuis 21 ans
il veut donner confiance aux réunionnais
et leur dire que vous avez des idées
inscrivez vous travaillez votre projet
autour de nous nous avons des
partenaires et des partenaires solides
qui sont là pour vous accompagner dans
vos projets et pour que vos projets se
réalisent et se pérennise
pour didier ce concours est une
révélation le projet de l'entrepreneur a
tapé dans l'oeil des organisateurs on
met 2 340 enfin 150 euros pkoi et donc
ils s'additionnent 14 quand ton nom
tiken jah déjà tu as gagné déjà été bien
thon rouge est en projet plaît déjà et
de tatous dû faire là c'est génial super
sensation au livre optical in fait
finalement partie des sept lauréats
finalistes et rafle le prix du jury
quand tu te relèves rien tu gagnes 7000
euros
moi les 7000 euros j'ai pu investir dans
du matériel un peu plus spécifique aux
personnes aux jeunes handicapés monture
peu plus souple qui se casse pas plus
résistant en fait 7 apporte de la
visibilité
tu passes à la télé parce que c'est sûr
question press book
les gens appellent aujourd'hui c'est à
l'appel d'une mère et sa fille que
l'opticien doit répondre je vais un
enfant qui
qui a dit sur thon rouge qui est
les autistes on a déjà passé l'étape de
la la commande là on va livrer son
équipement
bonjour bien pour myriam la cliente
c'est une première et la mère de famille
voit d'un très bon oeil l'initiative du
jeune practicien c'est lena qui avait
besoin de lunettes
et puis on va parler vivier j'ai trouvé
ça super bien donc j'ai appelé il est
très réactif j'ai envoyé un message le
matin l'après midi me répondait le
lendemain on avait rendez-vous agréable
plus nom n'est pas stressé dans un
magasin regarder ya tellement de
l'ailette
et puis nous conseille très bien
première fois du coup tu vas porter des
lunettes convaincu myriam en profite
pour rétablir elle aussi un devis une
commande de plus pour didier est un
petit pas supplémentaire sur la route de
la pérennité car malgré la
reconnaissance du concours le chemin de
la réussite est encore long même si
l'entrepreneur ne perd pas de vue son
objectif
c'est pas simple c'est super compliqué
c'est encore compliqué même jour mais ça
t'apporte beaucoup
quand tu te réveilles le matin et que tu
moi dans mon cas où je me dis que je
vais les aider des gens sales quand même
vivre moi et en plus être bien dans ma
tête
[Musique]
le challenge est créateur est un
concours créé par le département en 1998
pour valoriser les entrepreneurs
réunionnais qui créent leur propre
emploi il récompense sept lauréats deux
catégories différentes
en leur attribuant les dotations de 7000
euros chacun cette année le concours
s'adresse à tout chef d'entreprise ayant
créé son activité entre le 1er juillet
2016 et le 31 décembre 2017
les candidats doivent être demandeur
d'emploi bénéficier de minima sociaux au
moment de la création
les inscriptions en ligne sont ouverts
jusqu'au 17 septembre 2018 aminé sur le
site du département au www.defirh.fr
cap.fr bien social accompagne la violer
pour la mobilité
michel damien de la réunion et
la montagne aujourd'hui gérant d'un
salon de coiffure
on a une partie du salon qui consacrait
aussi au défilé fashion omis les petites
choses comme ça le strass et paillettes
de tout le temps d'adaptation en fait
c'est le temps de rencontrer des gens
d'avoir des affinités et une fois qu'on
a ça c'est tout c'est parti c'est quoi
un des points qui m'a donné envie aussi
mais c'est d'apprendre à connaître la
france par ligne et tout ça pour aussi
d'un faire voyager des parents ma plus
grande satisfaction me lever le matin et
me disait que je vais aller chercher les
clés de mon salon
[Musique]